252 subscribers what is going on guys
hold on we're the 15 this video will be
a lot lower quality than you're used to
from the channel I don't have access to
a computer that can do the same type of
editing that I usually do for my videos
because i'm at home for the week and
it's spring break for my school and
that's why there hasn't been any
activity on the channel and I haven't
been releasing videos but that all that
I can't talk that will all change on
Saturday I've got some videos coming up
and they're really good and so stay
tuned but that's not what this video
hold on to someone watching me that's
awkward I don't like people watching me
when I'm filming a video I'm still
self-consciousness I'm not you know a
big youtuber yet so I'm not okay with
the vlogging everywhere what was I going
to say 250 subscriber giveaway so the
way I'm going to do this is I'm going to
pull names from a hat and that's really
primitive way of doing things but I
thought it was kind of cool and old
school and obviously we won't be able to
do this forever because the channel is
growing and there'll be too many names
and I don't want to cut up that many
piece of paper but for now we can do it
this way and that's really cool what am
I getting away so the winner of this
contest oh my god it's just all so again
the winner of this contest will win the
a they will win ok there's the logo they
will win an iPhone case with the better
ideas will go on it it could be
redesigned because I think that looks
pretty ugly at the moment so i'll be in
contact with you to see what kind of
phone you have it might say like better
ideas right there also bet ideas mug
hold on you can't even do that look like
that's good I'm losing you guys losing
your attention regardless and also a
ten-dollar amazon gift card so that's
the giveaway let's do the names from the
Hat
sad that these are my subscribers
doesn't look like many I mean it's not
all the subscribers the people who have
commented as well so I'm just going to
pull around the main here and the winner
is Matt crouch if you can see that let's
have Matt crouch so Matt croach you are
the winner of the 250 subscribe give
away I will send you a youtube message
so we can be in contact and we can
figure out your details and stuff like
that so I know a lot of people don't
check their YouTube messages but that's
how I'm going to contact you I'm going
to contact your YouTube messages I think
you can go on the like your YouTube
dashboard feel like the top right your
YouTube channel and you can maybe I'm
wrong either way you can look up a
google tutorial YouTube tutorial see how
whatever on how to check your youtube
messages because that's how I'm going to
contact you what else thank you so much
for subscribing guys everyone who
subscribed 250 subscribers is kind of
crazy I've never reached that many
subscribers that fast before on any of
my channels and the majority of you
aren't people I know really well or are
not immediate family so that's kind of a
good good changeup I'm really tired I
can barely talk but i'm going to go I'm
gonna hit the gym anyways see I'm
stuttering everywhere this is
embarrassing for me I'm going to turn
the video off now and I hope you all
have a nice day subscribe if you haven't
already and I'll catch you in the next
video